i've drawn an arbitrary triangle right
over here and i've labeled the measures
of the interior angles the measure of
this angle is x this one's y this one is
z and what i want to prove is that the
sum of the measures of the interior
angles of a triangle that x plus y plus
z is equal to 180 degrees
and the way that i'm going to do it is
using our knowledge of parallel lines or
transversals of parallel lines and
corresponding angles and to do that i'm
going to extend each of these sides of
the triangle which right now are line
segments but extend them into lines so
this side down here
if i keep going
if i keep going on and on forever in the
same directions then now all of a sudden
i have an orange i have an orange line
and what i want to do is construct
another line that is parallel to the
orange line that goes through
this vertex of the triangle right over
here and i can always do that
i can just start from this point and go
in the same direction as this line and i
will never intersect i'm not getting any
closer or further away
from
that line so i'm never going to
intersect i'm never going to intersect
that line so these two lines right over
here
are parallel this is parallel to that
now i'm going to go to the other two
sides of my original triangle and extend
them into lines
so i'm going to extend this one into a
line so do that as neatly as i can
so i'm going to extend that into a line
and you see that this is clearly a
transversal of these two parallel lines
now if we have a transversal here then
that means and we of two parallel lines
we must have some corresponding angles
and we see that this angle is formed
when the transversal intersects the
bottom orange line well what's the
corresponding angle when the transversal
intersects this top blue line what's the
angle on the top right of the
intersection angle on the top right of
the intersection must also be x
the other thing that pops out at you is
there's another vertical angle with x
another angle that must be equivalent on
the opposite side of this intersection
you have you have this angle right over
here these two angles are vertical so if
this has measure x then this one must
have measure measure x as well
let's do the same thing with the last
side of the triangle that we have not
extended into a line yet so let's do
that so if we take this one
so we just keep going so it becomes a
line so now it becomes a transversal of
the two parallel lines just like the
magenta line did
and we say hey look this angle y right
over here this angle is formed from the
intersection of the transversal and the
bottom parallel line what angle does it
correspond to up here well this is kind
of on the left side of the intersection
it corresponds to this angle right over
here where the green line the green
transversal intersects the blue parallel
line well what angle is vertical to it
well this angle so this is going to have
angle or it's going to have measure y as
well
so now we're really at the home stretch
of our proof because we will see that
the measure
we have this angle and this angle this
has measure angle x this has measure z
they're both adjacent angles if we take
if we take the two outer rays that form
the angle and we think about this angle
right over here what's this measure of
this what's this measure of this wide
angle right over there what's going to
be x
plus z
x plus z
and that angle is supplementary
is supplementary to this angle right
over here that has measure y
so the measure of x measure the measure
of this wide angle which is x plus z
plus the measure of this magenta angle
which is y
must be equal to 180 degrees because
these two angles are supplementary so x
so the measure of the wide angle x plus
z
plus the measure of the magenta angle
which is supplementary to the wide angle
it must be equal to 180 degrees because
they are supplementary
well we could just reorder this if we
want to put in alphabetical order but
we've just completed our proof the
measure of the interior angles of the
triangle x plus z plus y we could write
this as
x plus y plus z if the lack of
alphabetical order is making you
uncomfortable we could just rewrite this
as x plus y plus z
is equal to 180 degrees and we are done